mit diesen haaren wurde er vom friseur
zum star
die punk frisur von fürstin gloria von
thurn und taxis kundin von ihm gerhard
maier dem promi friseur aus münchen
unser auto war die hochzeit von der ma
ja ganz gern und dann sind die
natürlichen der residenz ausgeflippt und
dann kam dieses waren sie die pflanze
über die wollten sie alle haben die
haben uns ja alle gebuhlt
[Musik]
ende juli noch besuchte bild gerhard
maier in seinem salon mit seiner
berühmtesten und 1 schrillsten kundin
vorjahr von thurn und taxis
[Musik]
die kettenkamper weg sind
heute nun trauert münchens promi-szene
um gerhard maier gestern früh fand eine
angestellte seine leiche in seiner
wohnung gleich in der nähe des salons
naja war nicht zur arbeit erschienen und
am abend zuvor so heißt es genehmigte er
sich noch ein deftiges essen
schweinebraten voll lebensfreude
am morgen danach war er dann tot mit 65
jahren die ursache seines todes noch
unklar
meyers krankenakte allerdings war lang
2018 hatte er einen schwächeanfall in
seinem salon eliten zuvor burnout
schlaganfall mehrere herzattacken sein
freund und konkurrent oder walz heute
tief betroffen
er hat ganz münchen schick gemacht ich
habe ihn nicht nur als freund sondern
auch als kollegen sehr geschätzt und ihm
immer gesagt gerhard für mich bist du
der füllen weltmeister und auch promi
journalist michael graeter sprach heute
mit bild über den tod gerhard man ins
tal gestürzt und selten waren 516 wissen
der heutigen zeit kein alter mehr
[Musik]
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren